back in june of 2016 the
united kingdom had a referendum vote
about whether they wanted to leave
the european union this was called
brexit
the referendum results were 51.9 percent
of voters saying
we want to go and that was the beginning
of making brexit a reality and
right when this happened there were
questions about well what's the timeline
is it going to happen at all how would
it happen
what's going to be put in place in terms
of trade policy
employment across uh countries migration
between the uk
and the eu and in the two and a half
years since the vote there have been a
whole bunch of
sensible questions asked about is this
all failing
uh it's been so long should there really
not be a new referendum ballot to see if
the population even still wants to do
this because it was such a slim
margin two and a half years ago but
nevertheless
the timing remains as of right now
that brexit is set to happen on march
29th the latest milestone was
okay how do we leave and prime minister
theresa may had this plan
that was going to be voted on which
would establish the exact process for
leaving the european union
why do you need a plan at all because as
you can imagine if you leave the eu
without a plan in place it would be a
complete and total disaster so theresa
may puts forward this plan
and yesterday there's a vote taken on it
the teresa may plan
was defeated so soundly it went down in
flames
losing 432 to 202
and it was expected to lose but but not
necessarily by this record
margin and what's really important here
is that there's a misunderstanding
that some people in our audience have
i'm seeing a few emails coming about
this
this doesn't mean brexit is canceled
okay this means that
theresa may's plan for how to do brexit
has failed
so there's still a deadline of march
29th there's no serious plan for exactly
how it's going to work
so now the next steps are number one
can they still keep the march 29th date
or does that have to get pushed back
number two does the reese does teresa
may survive this because there's a no
confidence vote set for today
may be going on right now as we're
filming today's program and she may not
even survive as the prime minister
after this fiasco so there's a couple
different paths forward
one is at this point should the entire
thing be cancelled
should it go forward or should it be
delayed number two
should there be a new referendum ballot
which by all measures i've read pat
would now
fail it was such a small margin to begin
with a lot
of uh people in the uk have now seen how
it is turning into a complete and total
disaster it's leading to fears about
food shortages as we've talked about uh
people buying
uh basically becoming preppers
stockpiling food for what might come as
a result of brexit so should there be a
new ballot which would
according to many uh now opt to remain
in the european union and the number
three is theresa may going to survive
this
i'm increasingly of the mindset pat that
theresa may is going to have to go
uh yeah i'm not sure about that one but
i do know that members of theresa may's
team
have commented saying that if their
brexit plan failed
they would consider it having a second
referendum and many other members of
parliament had
have said things to that effect too uh
it may be a little bit of an
embarrassment to put out a second
reference referendum and
maybe that would come across as
undermining the will of the voters
because they did vote for brexit two and
a half years ago
but if they were to have a second
referendum now with all we know about
brexit and the implications of it i
think it would fail i mean i think i
think
60 of the country right now wants to
stay in the european union and i think
there's a good case to be made that you
should have that second vote
well they have a couple of options as
you mentioned number one is
you exit the european union without a
plan in place that's probably not good
for the british economy people in the uk
as i mentioned bracing for food
shortages they're buying dried food
supplies it could get really ugly
option two is you cancel brexit
realistically this is actually the best
decision economically
and in in more or less every sense but
they would look a little silly
if if after all this they say hey you
know what we're actually just not going
to do it
but i actually think it should be
encouraged to be
said it was a mistake okay the decision
barely got fifty percent
in the two and a half years since we've
realized or at least more people realize
we've gone from uh 49 percent to 60
percent of the population realizing that
it was a mistake
if we voted again it would fail clearly
let's cancel the entire thing
so i am going back to my day one
prediction
the day after brexit i said
this may never happen and i don't think
it is going to happen
i'm sticking with that i believe
ultimately brexit will not happen i'm
not willing to bet any money or anything
like that pat but i am maintaining my
same position
if you had to give us your most likely
scenario
does brexit happen or does brexit not
happen i think after this
failure they're going to have the second
referendum the country will decide that
they don't want to leave the european
union and brexit will fail
that's my prediction send us your
thoughts i want to hear from the
audience also interestingly
you might remember that the day after
brexit i believe it was i'm thinking off
the top of my head
american stocks dropped drastically i
think it was like a three and a half or
four percent decline in stocks
when brex when the initial brexit vote
happened yesterday
after the failure of theresa may's plan
to leave
stocks were up modestly and it sort of
seems as though
the reality of what's going on there has
been kind of priced
into the market so i think that that's
also interesting which is that
even the uncertainty about whether or
not brexit's going to happen and
how and what the impact could be it
seems to have been widely priced into at
least
american stock markets already of course
if brexit is completely cancelled
it's less clear what the response would
be from the american economy
but that's made increasingly complex now
given the interplay between the european
union
the uk the us and donald trump's tariffs
on a number of different countries
uh particularly china so it's going to
be interesting
the only prediction i'm willing to make
is that i still believe
brexit will not happen today's sponsor
is skillshare and i'm excited to tell
you that
everybody in our audience is getting two
entire months of free access to
skillshare
when you click the link underneath this
video skillshare is the site that offers
over
25 000 online courses on almost any
topic
you can imagine cooking meditation
photography
video editing photoshop managing a small
business
almost an endless list and whether
you're trying to get ahead in your
career
maybe you want to learn new skills that
will make you better at your job you
might just be exploring a new hobby
and you're trying to find new ways to be
creative in your personal time
skillshare is the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself
in whatever you're trying to learn i
really enjoyed
the class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something
i've been wanting to improve at but have
been very busy
hosting the david pakman show for the
last few years once again the david
pakman show is giving you
two whole months of access to every
single class offered by skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription
skillshare super affordable at less than
10 bucks a month
get better at whatever it is that you're
passionate about
or discover something brand new that you
didn't even know
that you would love and join
skillshare's other 7
million users by clicking the link
underneath this video